hi there i'm kerry smith from nature
publishing group
in this screencast i'll be talking about
our new desktop widgets for searching
nature.com
first of all what are widgets widgets
are fun mini applications which run in
the sidelines on your computer and focus
on handling one single task
they're designed to let you get on with
your normal activities while being ready
for you at a moment's notice
this is the new nature.com search widget
which we've developed for searching our
database of over half a million research
articles and news items
i'm using it on a mac for this
screencast but you can also get to it on
a pc using yahoo widgets
okay so let's start with something
simple say i want to search for articles
about
dinosaurs all i need to do is type my
query into the widget like so
and press return to run the search
there we go as you can see my search
results come back listed in an easy to
read itemized format which you can
browse through using the scroll bar here
if what you're looking for isn't on the
page you can also use the arrows up here
to page back and forth through the full
set of results
all of the results returned by the
widget link through to the corresponding
article on nature.com
so to read one of the articles listed in
the results or get more information
about it
you just need to click on the title of
the article
and it will open up in your web browser
like so
so that's how you search for articles on
any general subject
but what if you need to be more exact
for example say i'm looking for a
particular article on climate change
that i read in nature reports
but i can't remember the title of it now
and i can't seem to find it doing
keyword searches alone
what i can do in this case is open up
the fielded search form by clicking on
this button here
on this form not only can you search
keywords using any words from the full
text of the article
but you can also search using more
specific details such as
title author date volume
issue or page number better yet
if you know the doi of the article
you're after you can just enter that
unfortunately i don't know the doi for
this article but i do remember the
author's name was something smith
so i'll put that in here
and the article must have been fairly
recent published in the last year or two
so i'll add that date range in here
and here
let's see how we go with that
hmm this isn't looking too good i can
see up here that it's found almost 400
articles that match my query
that's a few too many for me to want to
look through i'll need to narrow my
search down a bit more
so let's go back to the search form
notice down here there's a little info
button you can click to change the
settings of the widget
you can use this to choose which
journals you're searching let's do that
now
here i can either select all journals or
else check off individually just those
that i'm interested in searching
so in this case i'll scroll down the
list until i find the journal i'm
looking for
nature reports climate change and check
that journal
then when i'm finished i just have to
click done down here
and my preferences will be remembered
okay let's try that now
aha that's the one i was after by the
way in case you were wondering how this
widget works
it's using the new nature.com open
search service which we've recently
released
to make things like this widget possible
this service uses open technologies to
distribute access to our search
so that your application and our search
engine can talk directly to each other
you can even see the actual search that
is sent to nature.com open search
by peeking behind the form here but
that's enough for that technical stuff
so that was just a quick overview of the
nature.com search widget
have fun using the new tool for more
information
visit our widgets page at nature.com
widgets